NEXT.
LOOK UP FROM YOUR PHONE.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
MYSTERIOUS.
IT IS ONLY FOCAL PAGES LONG.
IT IS CLASSIFIED.
THAT MEANS WHILE MANY ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT, AND THEY ARE,
VIRTUALLY NOBODY HAS READ IT.
APPARENTLY DESCRIBES
SURVEILLANCE OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS IN THIS COUNTRY BY OUR
SOME REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE SEEN
THE DOCUMENTS IT EXPOSES MASSIVE
COMMITTED FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
THEY SAY THE MEMO SHOWS HOW THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IS THE
THIS COUNTRY FROM FOREIGN
THREATS LIKE TERROR, WHICH IS
ITS PURPOSE, BUT TO SPY ON RIVAL
CAMPAIGNS.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN
PARTICULAR.
AND TO CREATE A PRETEXT FOR THE
CURRENT INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION, ONE THAT HAS
MESMERIZED OUR CLASS AND
PARALYZED OUR GOVERNMENT, EVEN
TODAY THE PERSON WAS RESPONDING
TO QUESTIONS ON EDGE.
WATCH.
>> ONE MORE QUICK ONE.
>> I ONLY REPEAT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF MAKING SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND.
WOULD BE FAIR TO YOU?
>> WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT.
HERE IS WHAT WE'LL SAY, AND
EVERYONE SAYS.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING, OH, WELL,
DID YOU FIGHT BACK.
DONE.
FIGHT BACK?
OH, IT'S OBSTRUCTION.
HERE'S THE THING, I HOPE SO.
>> HOW DO YOU DEFINE COLLUSION?
>> YOU'RE GOING TO DEFINE IT FOR
ME, OKAY?
I CAN TELL YOU.
THERE'S NO COLLUSION.
I COULDN'T HAVE CARED LESS ABOUT
RUSSIANS HAVING TO DO WITH MY
CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: THAT'S ALL WE TALK
ABOUT IN WASHINGTON PRETTY MUCH.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT THIS WHOLE
INVESTIGATION IS A POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED SHAM, THAT WILL BE
NEWSWORTHY.
IN THE WORDS OF ONE SITTING
WORDS OF CONGRESS, "WHEN THIS
MEMO COMES OUT, PEOPLE WILL GO
TO JAIL."
IS THE MEMO THAT?
WASHINGTON, WE HAVEN'T READ IT
WORD OF IT.
THE MOST DESTABILIZING THING ANY
GOVERNMENT CAN DO IS USE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS A POLITICAL
WEAPON.
THAT IS WHEN THE POLICE, THE
SECRET POLICE.
OUR FOUNDERS WERE RIGHT ABOUT
THAT HAPPENING HERE.
THE REST OF US OUGHT TO BE
WORRIED TOO PAID A ROGUE FBI IS
A FAR BIGGER THREAT TO YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY THAN ANY BUFFOONISHT
YOUR FAMILY THAN ANY BUFFOONISHE
YOUR FAMILY THAN ANY BUFFOONISHF
YOUR FAMILY THAN ANY BUFFOONISHO
YOUR FAMILY THAN ANY BUFFOONISHM
THE OVAL OFFICE.
IT COULD WRECK EVERYTHING WE'VE
BUILT HERE.
THE PUBLIC DESERVES, NO, IT
NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT IS IN THAT
MEMO.
THIS IS OUR GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW IF IT IS
REPRESENTING US WILL FIND TO OUR
FACES.
TRANSPARENCY IS THE ONLY
ANTIDOTE.
YOU WOULD THINK EVERYONE WOULD
AGREE WITH THAT SENTIMENT.
IT'S PRETTY COMMONPLACE.
THAT?
SECRECY IS GOOD?
PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW IF THEIR
GOVERNMENT IS CORRUPT?
OUR DARKNESS AND CORRUPTION,
PLEASE.
EVEN IN WASHINGTON, YOU CAN'T
SAY THOSE THINGS OUT LOUD,
THOUGH MANY WOULD LIKE TO, TRUST
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD H
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD V
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD E
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD A
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD N
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD W
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD A
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD G
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD Y
HANDMAIDENS IN THE MEDIA COULD U
NOT ALLOWED TO KNOW WHAT IS IN
THAT IS IN THAT MEMO BECAUSE
RUSSIA.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE MAKING,
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND ADAM
SCHAFFER WARNING THAT IF YOU
WANT TO READ THAT DOCUMENT, THAT
MEMO, WHICH, BY THE WAY,
PREPARED BY THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
FOR ALL AMERICAN LAWMAKERS, YOU
ARE SOMEHOW IN LEAGUE WITH THE
VLADIMIR PUTIN REGIME.
YESTERDAY, THOSE TWO SENT A
LETTER CLAIMING THAT CALLS TO
ATTACK BY THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
TO KREMLIN-LINKED SOCIAL MEDIA
ACTORS DIRECTLY ACTING TO
INTERVENE AND INFLUENCE OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS."
TRANSPARENCY FROM THIS
GOVERNMENT AND THE SHOW, AMONG
OTHERS, IS PARTICIPATING IN A
FORM PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN THAT
HURTS AMERICA.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE.
THE IMPLICATION OF THE LETTER IS
THAT TWITTER AND FACEBOOK OUGHT
TO DO SOMETHING TO HELP, BY THE
WAY, QUICKLY, LIKE SENSE OF THE
ACCOUNTS OF ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
SEE THE MEMO.
FIGHT EFFORTS BY POLITICIANS AND
THOSE IN POWER TO HIDE
UNFLATTERING INFORMATION ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
THAT WAS NOBLE WORK.
IT IS THE REASON THE PRICES
THEY ARE NOT DOING THAT ANYMORE.
ON TELEVISION TODAY YOU HEARD
FAMOUS ANCHORS MAKE THE OPPOSITE
CASE.
THEY SUGGESTED THAT CALLS TO
RELEASE THE MEMO ARE SIMPLY
TACTICS BY RIGHT-WING CRAZIES
AND VLADIMIR PUTIN TO UNDERMINE
AMERICA BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNPATRIOTIC.
AND THAT IS WHEN YOU KNEW IT WAS
OVER, THE LONG END WHERE THE